هنا بنرداغ بولايه غازي عنتاب كما في باقي
الولايات ال11 المتضرره من الزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا قبل ثلاثه اشهر لاثر هنا للصراع
سياسي المحتدم بين ابرز مرشحي الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاكثر اهميه في تاريخ تركيا
الحديث رجب طيب اردوغان وكيليشدار اوغلو
ما يبدو هنا فقط اثار هذه الكارثه
وما تمكنت الحكومه التركيه من رفع اطنان
التي
خلفتها هذه الكارثه فيما يبدو جليا ان
التحديات ما تزال كبيره تواجه من سيكون
الرئيس الثالث عشر لتركيا من اجل ازاله
اثار هذه الكارثه عشرات الالاف من المباني
الاله للسقوط وايضا لاسكان مئات الالاف من
المتضررين الذين اصبحوا مشردين بدون ماوى
في الخيام وخارج مدنهم وحتى في الحاويات
والبيوت المؤقته
تحدى منزلي واصبح حطاما لا اهتم
بالانتخابات نحن نعيش في الخيام وقضينا
ثلاثه اشهر صعبه جدا
قضى اردوغان تفقدنا كثيرا منذ الكارثه لن
انتخب غيره لانه رئيس جيد واعطانا مساعدات
ماليه اما دوله
قامت باللازم منذ حدوث الزلزال بعد
الانتخابات اتوقع ان يتحسن الوضع اكثر
خصوصا اذا نجح اردوغان ضحايا الزلزال
يشكل خابات الرئاسيه التركيه ما نسبته 14%
من اعداد الناخبين المسجلين يعيشون في
مناطق الزلزال لكن الزلزال دفع بنحو
مليوني شخص منهم الى النزوح نحو ولايات
اخرى مواقفهم متباينه بين داعم للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان وحكومته املا في استمرار حكمه
وناقم على
منه
بسوءته
لملف اسوا كارثه في تاريخ تركيا الحديث
عبد القادر خربوش في قناتنا العربيه
والحدث من غازي عنتاب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات